good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight it turns out they were
all lying to you
the greasy cable show host the
self-righteous Obama administration
hacks the corrupt FBI leadership there
was no spying on the Trump campaign
that's they told us again and again for
over a year that's what they're still
telling us even as they simultaneously
admit that's what actually happened
that's what they did that's how dumb
they think you are by the way that's how
much contempt they have for you they
don't even bother to make rational
arguments anymore they just bark louder
and assume you will believe it today
disgraced bureaucrat Jim Comey claimed
the FBI didn't really spy on the Trump
campaign he said they use quote
confidential human sources which by the
way is what the FBI calls spies as Comey
put it facts matter hilarious but then
Comey turned serious or a serious as a
buffoon can spying on the Trump campaign
he said was quote tightly regulated and
essential to protecting the country come
he went on to point out that asking any
questions about any of this will quote
do lasting damage to America in other
words hey surfs shut up and obey we
could go on and on but you've been
watching television lately you know what
lies they're telling